by the way we're getting more wins from
the supreme court there's a big win just
came out
totally separate from the abortion issue
this was on the first amendment
there was a case in in boston over at
the boston city hall there are multiple
flagpoles that are standing there and
one of the flagpoles is
open to fly various flags the community
wants to put up and so they put all
sorts of flags up there and a christian
group wanted to fly a flag and boston
city hall said absolutely not you can't
do that the supreme court just ruled
that that was a violation of the
christian group's first amendment rights
the city had already approved more than
280 flag raisings over a dozen years
they only rejected one and that was camp
constitution's christian flag so this
was a unanimous supreme court decision
even the libs went went on with this and
said no you can't you can't just single
out the christians and say that you
don't get speech but every other group
in in the country does get speech this
is a really good opinion and actually a
justice stephen breyer who is a liberal
justice on the court he even got a
snarky little comment in there about how
ugly boston city hall is so he said that
uh
the flagpole at issue stands at the
entrance of boston city hall built in
the late 1960s boston city hall is a raw
concrete structure an example of the
brutalist style critics of the day
heralded it as a public building that
articulates its functions with strength
dignity grace and even glamour the
design has since proved somewhat more
controversial
see boston city hall named world's
ugliest building
which is true it is one of the ugliest
buildings in the world so i this was
generally speaking a wonderful decision
for conservatives for christians and yet
i knew i knew even as i read this
i knew putting my my little nostradamus
hat on taking out my crystal ball i knew
this is going to be used by the
satanists
the and not not two days later
the satanists come out and they say that
they want to raise their flag at city
hall
and uh the leader the co-founder of the
satanic temple says religious liberty is
a bedrock principle and a democracy and
religious liberty is dependent upon
government viewpoint neutrality
therefore we want to raise the satanic
flag over city hall
this is going to split people even on
the right the hardcore
libertarian types are probably going to
say yeah let the satanists raise their
flag viewpoint neutrality man and the
conservative people are going to say no
no we're not we're not going to tolerate
satanist flags flying above city hall
so who's right
well according to the principle that the
satanist articulated any flag should fly
right he said that we need viewpoint
neutrality the government cannot have
any views on any matter whatsoever it's
the same thing that anna kasparian was
articulating at the top of the show i
don't i i hate christianity and i'm not
a christian but but you can have your
christianity just don't impose it on me
she says as she's imposing her views on
us that's the
that's the satanist position viewpoint
neutrality conservatives know
there's no such thing as neutrality
first of all here's a little history
check here's a good rule of thumb what
would washington do what would the
founding fathers do what would the men
who built our country do do you think
they would they would exalt the raising
of a satanic flag as the high point of
the blessing of liberty no i don't think
so i think they would run the satanists
out of town on a rail and they would
probably deport them from the country
so no so what happened how did we end up
in this spot well the view that that
this guy articulated viewpoint
neutrality comes
in recent
years from a 1995 supreme court case
rosenberg versus rectors and visitors of
the university of virginia
this this case is really the beginning
of our national obsession with viewpoint
neutrality and and conservatives and
christians have have
really embraced this idea of viewpoint
neutrality because at the moment it's
protecting
religious people or it seems to be
protecting religious people from the
predations of an atheist culture but
it's a silly idea there is of course
there's no neutrality of course there is
no of course a political community has
the right and the obligation to say that
some things are good and some things are
bad every political community in the
history of the world has held things
sacred and and held other things taboo
there's no avoiding that we can bury our
heads in the sand and pretend otherwise
but that's not the case we have sacred
images today unfortunately the sacred
images in our country are the pride flag
the sacred images are the face of george
floyd the sacred images but we have them
and we have a whole liturgical calendar
we have
a culture and we have
ultimately religious views that must be
held because all politics ultimately
comes down to religion whether
anacasparian or the head of the satanic
temple want to admit it or not okay
when you look at our culture all around
us you'll notice that it is reflecting
everything
except for what we believe so it's time
to build our own culture i'm glad you
like that clip now
ring the bell subscribe get all those
notifications head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcast
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you